you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to anthem
launched a live stream on cam I'm John
bicep hey how are you doing I'm great
kids it's that you were ready to launch
into something there well it's not just
the two of us today so now I've been
joined by two of our very good friends
yes we have Simon Miller and Lottie Van
Praagh hello thank you for joining us in
our studio friends but you're still at
the end of the line of course I'm here
at least I'm here that's a there what
are we doing apart from making friends
we're playing anthem but like oh did I
did want to say we've balanced the shot
nicely I can knock you straight back
down we're playing we have been playing
a little bit so far it is of course its
launch day so happy launch day thanks I
didn't get you anything
we have been playing through a little
bit so we've advanced enough that we
have our own javelins we're also getting
some gratuitous butt shots and quick an
edge oh you had another adjective that
you're using is obviously a wizard I
just hang back and just deal that's my
thing yeah and me you know obviously
yeah you are the soldier you arrange
those because I ranging off into
Scotland anyway we should but we should
also mention that there is a competition
going on a trip with GameSpot at the
moment so if you were to head over to
the GameSpot Twitter that is Twitter
forward slash GameSpot and retweet their
tweet about anthem you will find it
should be there and tag three of your
friends do you would want to be in your
squad well then you could be in with a
chance to win for Xbox one anthem yeah
the idea being you have everything you
need for you and your friends to go and
team up and go and play the game if you
don't have four friends just tag random
people yeah and then they can join but
yes we we have some challenges planned
throughout the street yeah but for now
yeah basically yeah the name of the game
is we're going to play through some
story mission just do that free play is
gonna be fun challenges it's kind of
silly finish the key thing is we're
gonna play on hard because key thing
behind them is that you play as a team
and we reckon we got a good squad yeah I
think so what goals don't oversell us
positivity
all right let's do it we're already
actually in a mission we have to go
protect some they're probably dead by
the matter kiss sounds like they've
taken a bowl political direction do you
want to lead us yeah I mean I'm the one
in this guy so all right hey our blue
marker hey Marco all right this way I
mean I like you leaders but I'll go
first yeah nice AB okay here we go oh I
need to turn my gameplay volume up there
we go that's better that's more like it
so I'm I've had a few goes with the
storm character before so I'm getting a
little bit more off a with how it
controls and I am really really good for
the fact that I can stay in the air way
longer than you guys so it's a good team
[Laughter]
things can people hey guys raise your
mix suit huh hey mine is right here oh
is it clear
I was in a flare partyer ultimate I just
sorry I almost oh hold on
dogs naked dogs oh oh yeah there's quite
a few of them oh that's the sniper rifle
all right here we go that's more like it
so cam how much time would you say that
we've played through up to this point
well you play or you mean in the game in
in game right well I would say that
we've about an hour and 20 in maybe
we've done one mission and a bit free
play to give herself bear gear yeah so I
think that's probably as far as we're in
but this is not the first time you've
played right so if you did a bunch of
other stuff no I I was I was lucky to
have a chance to play with some good
friends from mine an MMO shoe video and
from IGN as well and we got to play the
VIP demo it was a couple of weeks back
there was a lot of fun I was playing a
storm then as well which is why I prom
with it this time because if we're
playing on hard I figure the best best
plan would be to play with a character
vaguely familiar with everything I just
learned friendly-fire is definitely not
a thing it's not on yeah I just shot you
so Simon and lasse if you played anthem
yes I played a bit of the early access
demo slash B to the head when it comes
out today is the first time actually
settling down with it properly after
obviously we had a little couple of
hours beforehand to get ready yeah good
because when you start the game you'll
notice were on different javelins when
you actually start the game that's not
the case but you will start in the
Ranger and then once you do the kind of
intro bits you can a lot to kid yeah and
look one of your choice so seven I
rather cheekily assigned this is what's
happening is you will play in this which
you guys were pick and Lahti you uh you
know you arrived and shouted that he
wanted
I mean it just suits my personality it
does big or go home
bold brash big shield a shield in the
studio my choice I feel like I'm living
you know choose it I've spun it in my
head so you see yeah I did that straight
eyes I I made this choice oh this was a
long game quick get in there get out I'm
all about it yeah like shopping it's
been in there yeah I'm playing like I'm
in one of many different grocery stores
you can get in the United Kingdom yes
am I being abandoned by my friends yes
my abandoned you mean you're being slow
yes well I've followed the rocker oh
wait no worse look I'm using my ultimate
in a bid to survive that is a whole lot
of health they don't have sorry you
think it the Cavalry's arriving good all
right I'm gonna just hang in the sky
all right Oh God in amongst the enemies
I've got a new elemental power that I've
not been using on the last missions and
it's taking a little while to get used
to I would say if you are wondering why
we're not looking at comments right now
the plan is to in between missions we're
gonna dive into the chat on gamespot on
youtube so if you have any questions for
ascend by all means fireman we're gonna
be too busy trying to be good at the
game it's quite intense as well ever
since we switch it to hard I know
surprisingly you do have to work as a
team otherwise otherwise you're going
down okay the first thing you did was
leave Seb alone
oh you just I think you guys just went
off in the wrong direction I'm sure
these guys know what they're doing they
put a plan I just enjoy myself too much
I forgot they were meant to be working
as a team one objective this is where we
learn the power of teaming what this
guy's saying it's okay we need to find
the missing arcanists okay rescue them
or Atkins okay Sammy do you want to you
want to enlighten us about your squad
name here I mean it's a story we talked
about earlier my my ridiculous game of
tag and obviously now and this is Rhino
thing and that's because when the
internet first came around I wanted to
have a cool email address was gunning
for that Rhino at hotmail.com it was
taken and Rhino man was taken Rhino
bloke was taken so I thought no one's
gonna have taken Rhino thing and lo and
behold I was right so that's now Who I
am
that was a lucky break really could have
gone either way
I know alright nothing people like to
say I may or may not have jumped in
ahead of you guys and also be down this
way this way sorry I distracted us with
Simon's story which was very good story
so that's it for me you're really here
for the story saving said oh god oh god
get on the ground
save your good friend a business partner
you're up Mac Simon go yeah oh it's big
turret hey all right
ultimate coming in here it goes that was
the problem okay honestly they ramped up
the amount of enemies you you as soon as
we stepped up too hard it really easy
don't notice the difference
absolutely okay let's take together no
let's not let's everyone off again would
I ever
oh oh so when you see red thing on the
ground that means a missiles incoming
fYI a red thing on the ground yeah yeah
I just happened it was like a weird red
shape on the ground and then I landed a
rifle bang big combo wombo we like that
very Miller I'm with you thanks man Oh
guys I'm reloading
Oh ed shirts I see I can see you from up
here so I'll just keep an eye on I'm
like house nerd Slayer doing she's doing
she's everywhere now everyone knows
grenades everyone converge on nerds lair
okay where is she all right here we go
where are you she's up here oh yeah with
you
okay so we've got to destroy these
stockpiles okay oh yeah the thing I'm
right next it oh all right that's one
down oh no that's made me really poorly
yeah it's all right you'll get better
where is stockpile number two here while
you're doing that I'm just shooting
enemies I'm kind of course my backup for
now that's right
just in the herd Simon exactly we'll go
and farming so I've actually I'm
confused as to where the stop L is all
right I've got it where that's with you
yeah
where is he where is your Z it's hot
guys I'm just going in you objectives
he'll everybody see what closed down
because loads more just born doing no I
think it's because we actually have
finally closed down the thing are are
good so now now it's just just things
that's the that's the problem that I get
I guess from being up in the sky is that
often I I missed out on all the leaflet
drops I got too into it
I got you Simon thanks man oh they
pulled them off
oh yeah mate it's that finger I think he
wants an ultimate yeah he really wanted
that or maybe an explosive sniper no
he's dead
oh yes that felt good that felt really
good
all right all right let's go well we did
it well done tell me let's see about
those anarchists where where the lutes
Pierre we follow a new waggle alright
Rhino The Dream's rhino definitely can't
be misconstrued Oh God
I died I'm hitting the ceiling and a
smooth landing
just like I intended I know it's really
important that we found the the arcanist
but I am really really making sure that
there's no lose I've missed ok where was
the news I didn't see the loop well
there was no there was no loot crate or
anything like that
but it's just they do get dropped from
time so here we go
I think my favorite thing in this game
oh no I'm about to wait I'll tell you
later
I'd like to run out of heat so one of
the things you can do if you're getting
close to overheating is fly through a
waterfall or directly into a mountain
okay oh yeah now also work and that
should cool
the flying is some of the best thing
about the yeah more games need to put
flying in it because it's just brilliant
yeah yeah hear that all racing games why
not right why not let's back to the
future right there no problem with that
also if you can manage to fly just above
the water level you'll see some spray
coming off the water that and it also
means you're getting cool no but don't
go too close otherwise yeah you just
laugh and slash wait for you guys no
you're not you're in the veins I was
away for you man look at this I thought
we were friends
I'm most upset with you camp because we
share a similar oh no I think I'm behind
now okay this time I'm not rushing in
I'm waiting for you guys
Flair party Flair party definitely a big
time now you can throw a few okay all
right yeah you're right you can you can
also throw them on people
all right enemies let's do this strategy
is lots of sniper over fight and attack
also that
oh I'm being targeted by a lot of
snipers there is a lot yeah they're
mainly shinny you you did a great job
I'll draw their fire
good old boy you guys a drop guard I
just shot a rocket know you like suicide
mission runs guys guys they flanked us
they did yeah I thought I was shooting
Simon accidentally but it was a bad guy
is a lot like the bad guy you're rolling
Redman nice work Simon teamwork yeah
yeah there's a lot we need to think of
some good quips for when we all unload
Errol to this yeah okay pretty soon I'm
gonna tell a great joke famous last
words
so there's lots of game on the ground
this time invest to get the site so we
got a little blip er the top that's
technical term
I think that's telling us follow the
blip all the blood burn you know where
you're going please go in the right
right this way what TURN RIGHT hard
right ahead
whoa
hey this man holy wacko guys Michael
seems to know what he's doing
all those that sounds to me like a
mistake hey if I did know steps in front
of sorry sorry sorry bug on the wrong
way everyone let's go straight on oh no
we are going the wrong way this is we're
outside the mission that's fine it's
good to farm friends cars come on start
a strike in there yeah it's less scary
good I'm nearly dead dropping some
chunks I'm gonna get Ryan a very angry
person in here
I got you Rayna thing thank you so
that's it that's twice in this round
that's bad for me it's poor it's all
right you are the squishiest nice oh
that would be why that was my ballasted
right in front of him then that was
awful by me I'm embarrassed they bounced
to be a part of the team now so I'm
embarrassed for you too happy a perfect
team I could say can I go through this
little hole God anyway he's there that
works that works good work team
three times oh I just - that's okay keep
him on his toes reloading well done that
was good feel like we're getting better
Hey
mission complete dude really all right
how about a 20 minutes for a mission
number one okay we get through a number
of missions we might okay so so what's
the plan at the end of each mission then
what we gonna do okay so when we land
back at fort Tarsus which is the hub
world for here at them here you could
say we should all get our XP of how
we've done in the game we're going to
use that to tally up who is the best and
all worst yeah okay so I'm worried I'm
not gonna lie the winner yes so from my
screen it does appear that the winner is
said six thousand two hundred seventy
four yeah I think I'm second yes 86 then
Oh Simon yes every time all right so
basically the idea being that we're
gonna use this as the basis of a whole
nother concept of this livestream okay
which is our anthem quiz right a very
important anthem quiz so the loser in
this case Lottie will be question asker
two rounds okay we all have a chance to
score some points here so I guess a
point each is up for grabs
yes so if we make sure you hold it close
okay I'm listening right the Ranger in
anthem has strong offensive
ability double defense ability to double
jump
yes the Ranger is a jack-of-all-trades
your squad needs but how long's the
question comes does it take on average
to become an expert in an ultra
competitive field is it a 10,000 hours
be one year see 30 days or D 13 million
four hundred and sixty eight thousand
minutes okay I'm gonna go for a holiday
forget which which like boots in gear
they probably get easier we all get a
point there is actually a second round
to this as well oh yeah two questions
although hold on we did get through that
mission in two minutes what one one for
now but we also have to do the next step
said which is at the end of each mission
whoever is last also has to take part in
the respray challenge yeah so that means
mostly gets to choose someone to get who
gets to respray they get one minute to
respray your javelin javelin as it is
you can choose who's going to go to the
forage you can go straight to the forage
from here I think don't you sell fish
salvage or lighting stuff and no I would
never do that under duress right so when
I just go now right so yeah you so let's
give you three spray challenge do we
have a roughly a minute on the clock
let's go for it Simon alright I'll time
you yellow Gary let's let's look at
lottery screen lotty think of things
that would make you look oh it can be as
possible
looking at the comments yeah like a very
attractive u2 thumbnail this is harder
to talk over this and is the game now
you're I'm liking what you're going for
a view gone for a decal as well because
I see there's a light blue strip is DK
I'm gonna keep a decal on ya just
because it makes it look even more crazy
I'm diggin it so far your 30 seconds in
Simon let's just start to pick around me
things I may have started timing about
20 seconds too late that's fine I didn't
start early promise oh yes I got
reaction if I get a reaction I'm going
with it that's how I've lived my whole
life yeah I think 10 seconds I'm really
attacked it as much as I'd I'd wanted
let's go with that and boom I'm done
thank you very much the decal kept still
keeps your original creation in line I
just kind of decorate it there's a lot
of time left so we go we got some
comments yeah um Ryan Blair on youtubers
say yeah has anyone wore a cape on their
first date no just me
I think is reference to Kemp Serbs cab
that's the best character because of the
Cape we should all start wearing more
cake the Cape is lovely and I can also I
can design the Cape so maybe like when I
come last you can you can maybe start
with the respray oh absolutely
absolutely everyone yeah everybody I I
did jump in very early to largely based
on is all covered together crime with a
K also said don't kill rabbits they are
friendly we haven't actually at the
opportunity what to grab its what is he
what's the G stand for my gross rabbits
maybe yes while you're looking for
comments by the way cam yes I'm going to
jump into the forge because we learn you
plan it's very very important to upgrade
your stuff between missions
otherwise you get absolutely obliterated
regeneration nation says I haven't been
I haven't been able to haven't been
able to sleep from excitement to get
back to playing game like this in years
so regeneration nation is very excited
um what else to else do we have
I'm actually gonna keep my firearms the
same as they were before hear me - yeah
I think that's smart that I don't have
anything new blast seal this is exactly
the same I would call desirable new
components increase gear recharge rate
by 50% add specialized storage for
enhanced marksman rifle ammunition I
don't really use that too much an
ascribe component increases ice damage
by 5% of base damage oh that's tempting
but the one I've got on at the moment
does massively buff my shields and based
on that last round
speaking of shields yeah I just unlocked
a spork year that would give us an
actual shield oh nice so we can all hide
underneath my spherical shield or maybe
behind it actually think it's a dome I
think it's the shield wind wall creates
a wall of wind at a set position that
block you put a windmill one way and
I'll put my shield the other pointy
shield yay and then we'll be fine it's
taken my sit there my rating up
significantly 229 now 2019 yeah I like
carrots gotten quite real all of a
sudden you've followed my naming loadout
so you come for ice boy yes I'm metal
boy yeah even though you're you're
playing as a female that's true yes true
and then Lottie is default loadout I
like that very good strong choice see
fault loadout battle cry marks enemies
and forces them to attack the Colossus
I'm drawing more people to death so you
have I choose death mode yeah what's how
perfect was that absorption of the
absorption of damage
is just death I'm not gonna be able to
sleep later we hold you a joke racist
it's a good point that you bring up
because as we load into our next game
we've got our final part of the
challenge I boot that up
yeah it's everyone anyone ready to jump
into your next game I am I seem to be
stocking up level six pistols all set
wanna shoot single fire from the hip hmm
all right I am I am loaded in my I left
the forge a little late sorry I was all
right can lead us okay lead us leader so
we'll come back and explore this for
Tarsus a bit later
yes another mission let's do it I'm so
it said if you want to do your free play
narrow do you want to jump into X
mission let's jump into the next mission
we can go into our free play challenge
that a little bit later on nice
so change mission that means next
mission is if we got one loaded up we
may need to go and oh speaking yeah I
think we do all right well we're going
we'll go and do that like a fool yeah
need to speak to yeah oh yeah just to
the left so in the name of hopping into
the mission quickly yeah so incursion
meet her meet with her agent currently
embedded with the regulator's she's
giving you her location at the camp
there may be Dominion presence there as
well
okay I realized I was speaking to the
wrong individual oh you are just we're
just having a nice chat
I've at the same room travel and gets me
I think you can hit B to skip three
quick we're having a nice chat I was one
thing I want to ignore I've no one
started to chat character just cuz she's
not giving me missions now
and then me and can't cam and I will get
them because I think she's also
responsible for upgrading a javelin so
mine's gonna break my problem all right
back into the suit yes you can't just
hold why to quick jump in or if you want
to look at watch the anime did climbing
into you you're very claustrophobic
looking but I'm sure incredibly comfy
yeah notice the padding okay so change
mission we want to do where it is
incursion yeah okay so make sure you
guys Squatch so we can't unlock grandmas
in one until we're level two Hegarty
these are all difficult so easy yeah
normal hard Pacific planetary grandmas
the one grandmas pursued Grandmaster
three javelin power of 500-plus
recommended a group of freelancers with
advanced synergistic synergize builds
making upwards now yeah is needed to
survive yeah okay we're not there yet
you want to be able to say that I am a
grandmaster of an for that Wow they
didn't they didn't go like you know semi
master master grand master his
grandmother once you get there your
grand that's it
launch s alright yep lunch ready lunch
okay so you go well I I'm hitting the
launch button let's see what happens
alright making cool okay so cam what is
the next part of the challenge next part
said we like to call the anthem anthem
anthem and do you explain the N squared
alright so the anthem anthem is we
realize that in the world of anthem in
for tarsus as far as we're aware they
don't have a national anthem which is
introduced some lines to it currently
doesn't have a tune doesn't need to be
written to a tune and at the end of this
stream we will sing the anthem brilliant
and so will all of you given how quickly
we got through that four
mission how many lines do we want to add
to the anthem let's start with with two
lines two lines yeah let's start with
two lines okay so who does it we all do
well if I came first do I need to think
first in the last have to do first and
last say mercy you and I are gonna add
the lines to the anthem all right the
crew ready to write down the anthem okay
crew ready this is the most important
job don't worry about the cameras just
get this bit right okay good so my my
first line is all glory to Tarsus
magnificent venue home yes this is
happening
I do you know justice like the rhyming
of venue and all right yeah we move on
with the game we need to rendezvous with
the agent okay all to the regulator can
follow your good friend Michael how I
live my life before you were home you
make my life complete my favorite thing
is when you go from there like hovering
sip boosting
you know my parody no no flight
mechanics is so smooth I think there's
there's some room here to have some kind
of like ring flying minigame I'd be up
for that when you're flying oh the
weather just taking a turn it's cooling
us down that's true
yes a sharp drop downward we all
together a little heavier than the I'm
enjoying Simon's re spray enemies are
gonna be able to see coming tomorrow
[Laughter]
sure is flying enemies alright this guy
punch them watch here we go but
everyone's got a punch one oh I missed
it I miss it's not easy I did it first
time I'm sorry but hopefully we have
overheats as well it's going for ibly
road alright this is this is proving to
be quite difficult cool me down water
Simon UN I see way too gung-ho I need to
I need to back off I don't know what
that is your characters well that's why
I'm trying to do it right because I'm
supposed to be the guy that gets in
there he gets out the problem is about
getting out we can together yeah there's
this go in let's just stand in the way
of it's only half of the thing anyone
could anyone nice to punch one of them
you oh I tried I was always rather
punching it with my gun the bullets for
my gun you that Librans exploded they do
tend to aim in a fire
Londyn wyvern Steve explodes all right
we've got a little ray radar marker oh
yeah
the Blippar flipper - wow it's right
beneath us Lotus I was about to say
something like mine's way can we go in a
circle eventually two two and half hours
of the stream just walking around this
thing I got it yes all right
okay run to be with oh oh wait a minute
oh right
I'm not running oh oh my god okay I'm
here
don't forget your shield-wall cam oh
yeah I forgot bite my shield oh I've got
a shield - awesome I asked you how to
deploy it my my hubris was my downfall
where are you down where is that where
is your location said the bit the bit
where it says said I'm gonna do my
lesson I'm on top of a wall I'm gonna
get my ultimate which is nearly there
yeah then I'm gonna come a game that's
all right it seems like it Altima time
learning the truth about teamwork here
right okay I'm late there's some cover
fire where are you that's not you that's
an enemy look for me three bombs do you
see the little orange blip on your s3
dinner yep as you down sir yeah I've
been yeah just hanging out come around
and waggle
all right projectile wall is up oh yeah
how do you do the wall again right
bumper and left bumper oh yeah I've got
dome over here you guys what protection
come in the dome I do want protection
come to the dome I blew up as soon as I
got oh they're right behind me oh my god
oh man this is crazy
whoa yesterday hard shoot shoot the
house they're coming from the house hi
whatever just shoot it the house is
better mm oh this could be a problem
oh I like a you're not sure can be a
problem how many bullets all right nerd
slaves in there go on
yes I need to get some weapon all right
this is going better there we go that's
what whoo oh wait there's another big
pile of them no I see them come in this
is gonna stop the mice words
okay ultimate is happening with this do
it do it do it I'm gonna go behind it
flank there we go baby all right
lots of whoa check tile barriers down Oh
missed him still up yeah
all right let the house I forgot a kill
room over here got a comb going
whereabouts are you man under the dome
velocity oh I'm completely out of ammo
for that one
shoot no I'm out of MIT all right switch
it up I got him I got him
I'm pistol in this house today good Oh
heavy I have you guys next to Lottie
destroy destroy it's not a house it's a
drill there we go all right it's down
how am i down again I am but the thing
is I really do go you know I try and be
front-line tactical warfare crazy person
I get I get dragged in yeah you know I
got a hundred xp for an ally revival
know what I want right now
for the Colossus it's ridiculous that
you chose the inside like that I know
it's very feeling when I got hey that's
what I should do should we should we
head up to that blue marker yeah I'm
really low on ammo that's my one pop all
right I will wait for you guys I might I
have literally one bullet for this gun
what's this this is a chest loot chest
where come to me where are you join me a
little I go all right there should there
should be lutes for you there is yes I
don't know delicious he needs it
the walls all right it's back then quite
a quite lightweight yeah
oh oh oh keep it up we're interrelating
oh it's a wolf that's your minerals
minerals everywhere yeah do we share
minerals yeah you do so if you pick it
up yeah yeah yes yeah you're still gonna
get it it's their food don't worry I got
you guys
flight suppression area that one thing
that gives my character an advantage
fine I'm opening it yeah who else wanted
to run in there and try flying I think
you can shoot the bombs you can but not
once they've exploded oh no all right
let's just clear these bombs out
some kind of home which will appreciate
the music at the moment as well it's
really good cheering yeah all right I
like this cave is cool yes we get
experience for shooting the bones but I
can still hover that's just icon yeah I
can't clear either which makes it really
easy find bombs I find one running into
it oh yeah so it's like this special
barrier in this room that stops your
flight
it's like electric barrier alright I
think we're about to get attacked I can
feel it right everyone reload all your
weapons all right
I'm reloaded I've even got a full
ultimate as well spinning where are you
where is waggle dancing I'm following
waggle off to the right yes I see
I see where we're going oh we can fly
again yeah I quite like that no fly bit
because it you have to fight against
what you've got used to all of a sudden
yeah seems interesting that's good back
in the air straight away do that again
water for cooling oh he said never sit
let's never do that again I think we're
about to answer another question area
this one's gonna be chock-full of
baddies Crystal Maze this is like a
special room you have to go in yeah
let's see what is thanks Lloyd no one
else agreed well I appreciate it
well right where I grew up there was a
crystal maze that you could take part in
really yeah it was awesome
no he's probably gonna be fine
this guy's not gonna either a violet guy
this giant man like hey you thought you
thought this guy was big till you see
this guy Wow a lot of armor as well
he is huge his arms a little sure no
one's gonna tell him that yeah I'm I
said what's the box the reach advantage
oh man this guy's bad news I want to
fight maybe he just got really deep
voice big fan of leather maybe he's on
our team do you know what there's
something about him I think he's
probably not you'll be fine bouldering
from all of that hell let's go I'd like
to say this is a terrible idea
yeah gonna work freelancer four of them
that's how I talk to freelancers in
Orion I like how you said how useless as
well because I don't work myself what I
get for having dreams let's go respawn
restricted area is my new worst
nightmare and it just flashed up on
screen yes we are we are in a firefight
minion yeah it's it's good job they
chose to be evil though because you
couldn't couldn't sell like I don't know
flowers or something can be killed the
minute I go to Dominion florist wow I
think I probably dropped the ultimate a
little early Oh everywhere
give you guys a little shield ultimate
hey thanks man that's perfect timing
yeah
shields a guys have this dome I'm out of
ammo
oh I'm out of all I move that's a
problem you could be shield going thanks
man sir hey he's got your back man
Uub shield yeah no I'll be male a cut
that's pretty Bailey I'll be crashing
and go oh yeah let's find out if it was
healing energy oh no she's I just
stepped on her which probably didn't
help Simon just wow look see you
actually cracked the floor he did that
yeah that's awesome
I don't crack the floor yeah if you do
the jump marry minerals where scoop them
up for you no I think it's down there
not yep see underwater things cool isn't
it we just fly underwater they fly back
out again oh here we go there's minerals
down here okay yeah I just harvest got
three alloys
I don't I don't think we're actually
meant to be in the water no I'm just
mucking around the boy max so we're not
enjoyable where's the know I'm back oh
wait I thought that was a thought that
was water that was just a puddle
I went headlong into it okay I think
coming back at the entrance to the place
you want to be yep where's enemies
through there yep oh it's enough flight
area is this the room we were in before
it's a similar room yeah but there's new
guys that's all I need to know yeah but
are there gonna be palms everywhere no I
think it's a different room so I'm a
grenade hit the roof that's no good
all right guys I'm putting a dumb down
get the door be very camp thanks ma'am
all right see look at that projectile
fights off the dome haha my dog's gone
run who's shooting at me someone is
someone there he is there he has got him
oh god I just threw a grenade at Simon
again Simon stop looking like the enemy
dude that is not an excuse anymore it is
we have been teammates now for a good
half an hour or so and you still haven't
repaid I've got to lose to be respray
the baby's brain without fight
I've done it again I've got way too
close way to go there's some up there
who am i catching up with Simon yeah I'm
just trying to run away some of my life
just enjoy the day
there's nothing happened at the moment
nice nice where it's at
fight disabled yeah of course yes I got
hope from it when we need it
Oh sighting oh there we go flights back
place just in time to fly up here into
the ceiling into the ceiling all right
flights definitely back where the
baddies yep all right ultimate time oh
man is loads agree I don't see him I
said listen I exaggerated there's a few
oh man yeah carnage nice truck
one-a-days lovely use my mellow I've got
another shield if we need it it's there
and coming to you okay for shielding hey
pops all right where are you there we go
all done thanks sir
it's alright then we sat sitting the
shield and unload and reload there's
some kind of floating guy in the middle
is a year it's not me okay oh yeah oh
I'm down Oh guys don't screw this up the
boss appeared and immediately kill me
lotty yeah Oh me I'm going to try to eat
my health and their orange markers on
teamwork all right on our way he'll find
us I'll try I appreciate you the effort
Simon thanks man it's a doctor kiss oh
that did not go well at all latias all
on you this everyone's dead yeah it
seems that they've got a they've got us
pretty honed in there so just just
absorb damage nice pickup shield shield
this everywhere oh wow that was a really
dangerous place to be here oh that was
all you the team let's kill this weird
thing alright so I put a protection
check tile wall alright I don't know if
it's gonna don't come in the dome
come on the dome where is it that's
right there up here on the hill that's
the big big dope thing I've got my
ultimate so I can fly there I could fire
I've got my ultimate - I do but they'll
miss their nice down close I'm going in
I'm going in closer Oh
really really really clutch sad to the
nerd / oh man I'm so glad you were the
tank yeah that was great
that's sending the squishiest people to
save the squishiest people alright keep
arms down cuz I think I got a little bit
of an anxiety sweat in there Oh a nice
honest nah it's just a mineral thing
[Laughter]
there is a fan but it's been switched
off okay maybe we should turn that back
don't take your mic off it's so loud
alright wait someone plug that back in
Sam's got it sound the fan then alright
that's always good isn't it there is
some monitor before he escapes oh I
thought we were going back to the oh
here's your fly through the gonna say I
knew yeah you gotta feel it we're all
doing this right all together yes I
think I'm Way probably this is trying to
do this without burning out is probably
not possible you like to do with you
from from a pride point of view yeah I'm
gonna quickly landing so he's better
than land and
then over here yeah look yeah for a lot
longer if you do that all right
it's a writer thing space right nothing
your choice Miller good choice could
change it I just I want to start saying
it like people say ain't no thing right
no thing dude there's many ways to say
right he's all all right now here we go
oh my god and wolf from nowhere
I got him oh my god absolutely is this
going as horribly P you guys as it is
nope maybe yeah I'm getting nibbled by
something what is it well I'm trying to
destroy this turret with my bolts
getting out of here from within a dome
lieutenant person that looks like Seb
but not said let me let me put a wall
down for you
that's a good Altima that is if you like
melee attacks makes you feel like a king
no things are being hacked trap we were
fools who this flare will soar man I
think you can quote for the ages when
someone offers me work I'm like you
don't know the carriage at one point
that was lotty's mission as far as I'm
concerned yeah yeah come on come on four
big XP come on here we go
let's have a look go for XP this is more
intense than playing I think if we skill
oh wow come on skip to the end final
scores Wow
lotty you were not said oh say when just
edges me oh and by one service first
then me then Lottie and then Simon there
is love there a year one XP short of six
thousands it's that one XP to go second
last I need to do is save everyone yeah
my parents are watching I'm screwed
they'll never forgive me very well but I
think Lottie being the savior of the
team was yes I'm surprised that lot lot
you shouldn't you in the what the moral
victory yeah how works gone unnoticed
close it was I mean not me but everyone
else you're all kind of in the same it
was it was the same bracket only I was
only a few yeah yeah it was very clear I
did die up buncha time we all did we all
did very well
alright so some and I think that means
you are your quizmaster I didn't do
someone need to repaint me as well okay
the anthem cover art depicts the Ranger
interceptor Colossus and storm yes in
nature there are three different types
of thunderstorms which thunderstorm
creates a rotating updraft okay great
question a single cell B supercell C
jewel cell D multi cell you can a single
cell supercell C jewel sale sale it's
gone
jewel cells that was super I'll go see
jewel
supercell do you you invoke on BBC the
answer is B
oh man [ __ ] to t1 no no wait in-game
leader yes I am now make sense
make sense alright okay I think we've
unlocked the launch bay by the way here
we have nice Oh
level 9 gun hmm
nice so I I did I did skip through
that's a little quicker than I probably
should it on don't salvage eight is
great so what we got over here at the
back wow so it said explain the launch
Bay I did I skip through it it's awesome
oh is this where you can kind of
approaches upgrade yes with other
players who are non squad member the old
non squad is where am i why am i lying
there I would just throw flares what a
lovely old time
there is there's a sad boy thick in here
as well
stealing your name only one sick I think
we should break it back to the forwards
throwing yeah I'm going to so
regeneration nation and Rica I gaming
also knew the correct answer option B
cam could have done better here it was
easy
yes crime thanks thanks crying they
don't watch The Weather Channel lmao no
they do not know it does talk about CB
it's a little bit cold because super
cells everywhere you can press up to
send messages to other players yeah in
the launch Bay
I'll pay attention to the quick tear
okay so there's launch Bay before jeez
pay provides easy access to a forge
freelances customizer javelins oh
storage that's nice I like that that
really is where I should have been at
here in most of the kiosks here are most
of the kill so you find in for Tarsus
including the Alliance system contracts
board personal vault and the path to
glory so a lot of waste access missions
appearance options for you javelin okay
so it's every it's kind of like a whole
lot of quick access options in one
yeah I love it so where I was running
back to the forge I really should have
gone to the to the bay there on the left
yeah yeah so let's look at the story so
we'll need to get over to the bay anyway
because man is gonna need his javelin
respawns be expensive yeah I do need my
there being 18,000 gold I could I could
I could I want to buy I could spend it
all on one a moat that says I've got gum
on my shoe and it feels like I mean
siding okay activate Forge okay that's
good the forge
I need to quit my new guns are you guys
in here as well yes I'm well I don't
know if I'm in your one but I am in the
forge I'm just gonna go say hello to
people
hello mental madness you said nice
greetings friend oh wow we've designed
very similar javelins me in this guy oh
you really have yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
I'm looking to mentor you sounds like an
insult
so the alright where's this Forge at
quick Forge access oh my to my two new
guns are both level 9 and they have
upped my power level significantly loads
of stuff this is the dream wait where is
worse a quick Forge I know I was I
explained this whole room I was here yes
yeah hold X thank you new elemental
attacks focus seals capable of bouncing
off walls and seeking targets fires
powerful blast of ice energy racial
spirit come on said yes obviously your
spirit yeah I think that is actually a
more powerful soul dear
javelin live like a walking dictionary
yeah do I give this to be resprayed
you do but you have to pick who's gonna
do it I don't give it a lot it's only
fair yeah sir I don't wanna do a respray
okay okay all right can we do you want
me to time it some buffing up my javelin
excuse me minute is going I don't think
you can make anything look too bad in
everything it all looks kind of cool to
me
I usually have you said like you know
lime green but I'm not into it but look
it looks good all right what if we
online to go Christmas tree so is the
season when you're adding all the new
bits and pieces to your javelins it's
worth looking through all of the
different buffs and things they do as
well as just the power levels they up up
things by because a lot of them combo in
together so for my storm I've got things
where you know if I freeze a character
and then I attack it with another like
elemental attack like a another ice
attack you can get like buffed attack
damage on said character you got 15
seconds that's a pallet at least I what
was taken for the enemy anymore
thank you I think I look great green
green and orange what a combo so I can
increase the recharge rate in my gear
but it reduces the damage by 20% still
using this level especially for good
increases ice damage by 5% of base
damage and a FET build up less let's go
with the ice buff and that's it all
right
I'm gonna mix it up to level 9 weapons
can't go wrong
yeah I've taken some risks I'm taking
some stuff out that I think I prefer but
I actually think having the level 8
stuffing is going to benefit me more so
what's your newborn strategy cuz I'm I'm
up to 47 now cams on 60 what wolf behold
metal boy
yeah it's all the metal glorious
all right cool I just got a whole load
of level 9 gear see you're still using
the living flame whatever that is you
live down at level 4 keep getting that
plus on the let's let's jump into some
action because we are currently just
looking at lost in the menu it is quite
quite critical as well to make sure that
you have got your time for another line
of the anthem and that is true we've got
two more lines to give alright let's go
into the mission hold wine yep big with
tasin first we change mission let's find
out what do you want to jump into the
free play I think we do if we want to do
mission we have to speak to tacit after
about two for Tarsus so let's do that
let's go find him into that wall over
here yes it is okay find out what our
next mission is and then we can add some
anthem anthems who adds the lines in now
I can't remember the rules so it's the
first and last so Simon it's gonna be
you and me alright
better the game and then or worse I've
only just a my only charge a small fee
so where where are you right now Simon
I'm going to talk to this lady okay
well do you want to talk us through what
the mission is thing is you're doing
this first yeah you know when I talk to
the lady and the other guy his people
called him the monitor they're scared
about Dominion which is fair I would be
too okay the first time we weren't sure
is dead definitely dead
I'm sorry apologizing my people doesn't
seem that concerned at a woman force
damn I thought spies took everything in
stride we talk good this game looks like
genuine watching these people their
facial expressions yeah the guy speaking
to is like looking into my future
[Laughter]
so noble so I'm chatting to this guy
he's saying I was a freelancer for years
you know freelancers alike right
freelancer gag okay be bonding yeah I
think so needs to be a big
okay the first slide chasing the start
construction on for Tarsus was damaged
by a massive flood creating a series of
sinkholes after a thorough thorough
series of seismic tests construction
began again a different site regular
tests to perform under the current four
tasks to monitor the foundation
something about seismic tests we've got
it
except cool so we have also some
contracts we can do as well we got
choices now alright quick launch into
our quick launch yes nice okay so track
mission is protection thank you - yeah
yeah that's also the contract so I guess
this is our first contract which we have
to do now all right cool I have readied
up meters have I we're all ready lunch
I've hit launch so do we need it doesn't
matter we sing it at the end okay do we
all get to look back I don't think we
should I think we like sharks
so my next line is going to be the
freelancers life is a life of pain okay
freelancers low fat low fat pain and
then my slamming OH anthem Oh anthem
thou is to blaming magic okay so this
mission did we get the gist from from
the guy from future cam yeah it is that
there's seismic activity that we need to
go and investigate all right so we're
suddenly geologists yes we are now
they're like this freelance it seems
like a dangerous job yeah yeah
all the time I love that maybe there's
this other backstory of that's why it's
freelancers and it's just you doing odd
jobs
the handyman of the world silent
Christmas okay okay we're all cooled
when you said you were level seven yeah
Rhino thing is level four I saw that as
well I'm still level three apparently
sure this doesn't seem right no I don't
know never mind let's go and assist some
sentinels over the water cooling all
right hello sentinels by some friends
finally oh yeah I changed my weapons
imagine if he was real and that's what
you do on the battlefield you idiot this
gun literally goes peepee you amazing
all right where are all the bad guys to
kill ya I like when you weapon yeah it's
good you said that camera you don't do
time for your likes and dislikes I'm a
big fan of this gun
cannon like - uh-oh he goes how do you
change your second weapon
[Music]
Wow nice throws done throws him things
are on fire all right
hello friends and you glad we're here oh
god you big guys two big guys Oh
yesterday oh that is a good gun yeah
this guy town back to the sky as well Oh
uncle flamethrower smart place to be
I'm getting way too close again oh god
he's cheating me with the fire yeah
that's the worst thing about the fiery
guns is them you mean you can't fly
either they are dead
they'll kill I'm pretty hurt
Hey all right so at this point we are
just eliminating the star there's no
specific objective I believe that to be
the case yes all right
yeah that's gonna record now and saying
I enjoy the shooting muchly yes it's
very fun the guns feel like they're
actually firing sort of huge bullets
there is a weight to it yeah get that in
the flight as well it's not team spirit
at all yeah we should go have a reasoned
debate first defeat the outlaws all
right absolutely candy I'm gonna try
that flying above the water
no it just landed quickly
I'm gonna try on out guys are gonna try
and look cool I wasn't cool no matter
what you're saying before slime at about
how good this game let's say this sunny
Valley just flying through I am good for
ridiculous right the sheer depth of
field as well as I got the cooling
vapors I got them oh damn was cool
before I was don't go too far I got
excited
it sounds like some kind of pop record
you release
said cam was cool before I was oh [ __ ] I
screwed that right so where we going on
oh we're going to where there's I think
so we're set
started ahead of everyone else again oh
wow yet you know what playing a turret
with a pistol not a good call ultimate
however go well I didn't why did I try
and take on a turret quite a lot so I
don't know how I'm gonna thanks man
dumb time era thank you another valuable
lesson I've forgotten what power I put
on my what used to be the shield wall
cuz it's not a shield wall anymore
what's it I don't know what it is now
I've forgotten oh I just you're gonna do
that B I'm doing terribly if I can see
the musician my era is a beast
what is wind wall not worth it Lise you
have the decency to die behind a rock
this time I try I need to learn I can't
I can't
turret thank you very much okay you're
lucky we nearly got this guy oh he's
nearly got me very low health as well my
goodness it was a tree here oh no I'm
down I didn't really turn you get me
from there oh it's yeah I know right
that's why I keep struggling with that
he's got crazy reach all right no it's
late
I'm on my way okay I've completely
crumbled thank you so much let's do this
shoes through my defenses so Ryan a
thing the same thing we've learned a
lesson today ladies and gentlemen this
was nearly dad oh my God he's I'm down
I'm down
I think this thank you baby shoot all
right I'm gonna make my job just pulling
everyone up on their feet I know my job
just hiding behind his role think it was
a gay what oh I got knocked off -
there's guys coming from behind this
okay
cover Sam yeah navigate thank you well I
can
okay are we collecting over here
all right change up the guns let's go in
there you go all right finally it start
brings pain again where the bad guys are
they not back where the turrets there
they are they seem to be everywhere now
they've come out another one of their
houses over oh no I see what you mean
there there's a big red marks over here
being like fill this few over here they
seem like stragglers like yeah oh no
they said whoa there was a guy oh no
he's the boss character down yeah I
don't even know what happened that time
genuinely there's someone out there
who's really powerful no I'm down it's
the guy up there isn't it you stay alive
stay alive for the love of God stay
alive cam run cowardice cowardice is
your friend
oh it's that guy yeah guy looks like
said he was me sorry friends well we're
gonna go the whole way without ever
actually losing okay we're just a bunch
of losers
in our defense okay I think we need to
attack that a bit more as a team so team
oh my my shields don't last very long
against these guns together so yeah I do
I can put up a wall it does block
incoming projectiles I don't know if
that it's gonna be event okay let's
let's stay as a group say where is the
objective
it is literally backed away we're here
okay turn around go back there follow
set mm-hmm
all right we're gonna do much better
this time
very positive all right yeah we're back
in that lovely sunny Valley oh yeah that
one we died in nice place to go though
right yeah Lisa's picturesque you got to
go a minimum I'd ask for picturesque oh
yeah you doing the water fly yeah very
very cool I'm in the water
no did I ever shoot the objective oh I
did yeah we all did it's why we all
followed you so we all want to do the
water thing that was why it is important
to do it was worth it all right here we
are let's all come together let's all
staying like a square yeah oh okay I'm
gonna put this shield at the top of this
ramp here is a turret time I think so
say there is yeah it's a win wall oh
it's some kind of dome yeah I put the
dog that was me
I was it doing oh there's two domes here
we double domed and when there was new
in a row turret turret turret well it
seems to be working so we all shooting
the turret yeah yeah oh wait domes down
I'm taking lots of pain now ultimate
time oh I can't see it oh damn it just
out of view and you can't cancel the
I've got my ultimate well as a waste
I've got my ultimate mr. mell a thing so
much oh geez lunch one shot and you go
down from that thing yeah it's pretty
brutal
alright so we get closer done you got it
down it's not quite there he's nearly
dead look like he's down don't touch the
village we get behind it got him nice
nice that was gates there we go there's
another one there's another one there's
nothing I've got another dome so I'm
putting down a few others guys as well
there's guys I'm low health so it's
gonna he's pretty low
if anyone sees that guy my son play
again but we need to flank that turret
there's loads of got ice coming yeah
right I will try and take out the turret
because I thought I know let's all focus
let's all focus on the same thing
ok go for it alright you do the turret
and we'll keep the guys at bay so the
tarts frozen by the way
oh god I'm down there's someone thanks
to me where are you alright start sound
finally again that feels balanced now
the guy had a shot balance I got a shot
maybe when I pick up two more times if
we balanced alright thank you for saving
me much anytime cam
thanks guys there's a lot of enemies I
could do this electrical attack and then
if you guys combo with it alright let's
come together Hideo lots of enemies here
whose range hey can we just watch out
for that guy in the sky again cuz he's a
nightmare watch other guys throwing
bombs yeah we got him that was the bomb
right did it we're clear
where we looking all right remember your
Thank You forgeting I have dodge of
course yeah bees dodge yeah unless your
Lottie in which case I think it is just
shield yeah she's here oh god yeah is
because they all get special health I
thought I'd enemy was one of you okay
that's one down dome over here if you
want to get into them so powerful all
right thank you
all right we need to get Simon as well
thank you yeah that's great I've almost
got an ultimate she did you a bit more
races here everyone just fire them gosh
she is peril oh I'm frozen
I'm frozen oh my god I'm frozen great
tap 8fa I think yeah I said on the
ground like an ocean I mean if he's on
the ground combo is that it is he down
yeah no he's not down just put up in the
air sound he's down yeah he's done yeah
he's done yeah nice that was much better
oh there are few more left yep
oh I was a slightly overkill but tonight
I had like one left nice Oh another guy
Oh sugar
we're sorry I've got notes for this
flying that's the crazy guy right yeah
and dome and ultimate he's nearly done
he's done we just straight-up did that
much see when we played the team game is
it Lord
all right say we're gonna go find us a
freelancer okay okay this way Oh which
way the way of the blue marker oh yeah
I'll wait for you over here by the blue
marker me okay my alt is all charged
which is great
you guys coming you knew you weren't oh
man
it's fun flying as a four is just fun
yes formation Oh restricted respawn area
I'm gonna stand up here on top of this
tree okay
where is everyone they're okay um I just
don't you do this I have a sniper rifle
which I don't have
okay what's the objective lemonade oh I
missed him
where is the rest of them
I'm seeing a few oh there we go yeah one
of those trills just popped out of the
ground and with the freelancers here as
well I'm gonna get this drill it's down
that's quite a few coming now come by
time I mean time these guys are quite
squishy and I was that everyone that was
just a an early wave they were pretty
easy yeah that was a bit of a waste of
an old foot what are you gonna be the
big guy that's a big guy I've managed to
get my last
they're trying to flank you my loads of
guys I'm gonna let you keep him nice
oh that's too big guys yeah all right
putting a thumb down here I'm gonna see
just rub backwards if you get trouble
this is dumb here okay cool
oh he is flame throwing a lot yeah again
you can tell when the domes gonna go
down because it goes orange your shield
there we go
nice he's nearly nearly gun don't wait
to go watch app getting out of here got
it yes nice
Oh Pete go over there
I'm not really doing a lot of damage
turn through up here where is he he's on
the other side of that oh that's to them
lotty come bail it's dumb
oh no it's not it's not there yet sorry
I thought I had to go him but I didn't
okay
ultimate time I'm ultimately I can use
my manic crazy now they think one motor
guy yes I'm in get in there Oh got it
nice work
yeah he's down oh yeah and that's it end
of the game is getting harder and harder
yeah yeah
Flass feels like they had a good game
there no I'm worried there's mixed I
figured out how to sort of use my
abilities and all of my new weapons a
lot better so I'm more comfortable with
my sort of like combos and stuff they're
good I think I feel like there are a few
times you can mix up your new gear and
because not every weapon is the same
like the amount of accuracy or like the
rate of fire and everything with
different guns you jump in you're like
well this is completely different and
I'm gonna learn how to play all over
again
yeah come on surprise yourself Miller so
don't know what you were saying about
the levels earlier we're clearly all the
same yeah you've gone up to eight you've
just you're better just yeah nice
all right how do we do oh wow I think I
was much closer Lottie we tied oh you
did let's go yeah nice work
did I win again say once again is over
front clearly the storm Wizards yeah
that's it yeah or your skill ones yeah
for sure
so that means we have some new questions
[Music]
the X the exosuits in anthem are called
javelins yes another name for a javelin
is a pike a medieval spear yeah however
another term for a bike is a fish so the
question is what is the heaviest pike
ever caught in history thank you for
playing tenuous questions a 34 pounds oh
please 150 pounds see 55 pounds and my
favorite answer d pikes aren't real what
is the heaviest Pike ever caught in
history a 34 pounds be 150 pounds C 55
pounds 2.2 pounds in Aquila as I said
see ya see I was 34 B was 150 I'm gonna
go a then just so we go to the full
breath that big it would be in control
of planet yes the odds we see like you
for real man the real answer oh I'm so
sorry crime he says income it's easy
question can get it this time no I blame
or lack of here clean I do the problem
will happen here is I'm not very I'm too
streamlined and what's happening is
that's making me too obvious to the
enemies I think you get to choose who's
gonna respray well I mean we've got to
spread the love around so I will give it
all the way to the end let me go to
Carlo first okay recess and stop okay
okay let's just let's just oh I can
barely see what I'm doing this is good
it works for me let's go some Blues in
there and then go for the secondary hard
I'm gonna I'm gonna do so really weird
some like okay a birthday card you do
don't worry I'm gonna make you chemical
I'm gonna get rid of the green sorry
let's see okay yeah wait a minute wait
for it let's do this one some so you got
20 seconds left Cameron yellow you see
you hate yellow right Simon
I actually the secret like all colors
weird yeah four three green - that's
worse than mine
this looks like some sort of spider-man
code that's why spider-man yeah
like when you're mixing all of your
colors together in an art class and yes
that's beautiful
okay so I've I've unlocked a new javelin
have you guys know oh that's because
you're your level above us no no no
would you feel like but are you want it
you're gonna switch character or no I'm
gonna stay the storm okay cool
all right let me quickly retake some
weapons so we have a level 9 frag
grenade oh hold on II I it's it's made
me a colossus what storm please okay
let's see what weapons we go up there we
go
yeah let's take a look I really liked
the rifle I had last time marksman rifle
level 10 I just picked up duplicates of
my two existing weapons hooray have you
guys been remembering to salvage your
old stuff I have not been doing that I
have not either so I'm gonna do that so
basically you can salvage these guns
that you're no longer using for parts
and then you can craft using these
weapon parts mm-hmm I think the crafting
guns you have access to are kind of
locked to your levels so it's not that
you can go in and craft a stupidly
powerful weapon or something beyond I
think I accidentally equipped my most
basic Focus Blast seal last time it was
a level 4 and I had an 8 9 and a 10 I
could have been using I wouldn't I'm not
sure what denotes what you can craft
actually but I do you have a there are
some interesting options in here all
right anyway anywho that gives me extra
electrical damage but I don't have
anything electrical so we're just gonna
have to go with that grenade recharge
rate
combo damage yes all about the combos so
was that wind wall at all useful by the
way because I could I could instead
create a dome that regenerates our
powers much faster okay so I like your
powers
I think it's funny we mention this
because I've got a new dorm which will
increase gun damage to anyone shooting
inside the dorm will do yeah and I've
also got a shield one so we should pair
them so one of us as a shield one of us
has a well mine isn't a shield a dome it
is just a wall okay and what did they do
and the shield sorry the dome that I've
got you know yeah
allows us a 20 percent buff to the
recharge time of your support things
okay that's good so I've gone for that
trade-off right should we jump in this
mission
yep just quickly adding the the next
bits I've just kind of thrown normal
tactics out the window and I've gone
with if the number of the gun or item is
higher is gonee
more power more power more power screw
anything else that's what it's all about
that's how I live my real life I mean
see why I can't leave my anthem like
that well I know yeah live your best
anthem like live my second life that's
what they say I'm just gonna jump into
the comments and let's see what people
are saying sorry how do I change my yeah
I've got default okay are you going to
your javelins at the bottom with why oh
yes but it does reset it back to zero so
if you create a new okay here we go
Oh everyone's just everyone crime is
just really upset at me for getting
questions wrong Oh cam sad face seems
fair yeah okay oh my god people wanted
me to change the color to white but I
definitely didn't see that sorry Simon
right someone was asking and I've lost
it was asking oh yes I was asking what
the game is
this is anthem it is a game okay do we
need to go and see anyone before we
start our next mission I don't think so
change mission so I think we have one
option what researchers do not do
freelancers do protect if we look do we
not do this pertains very quickly
protect Erica said I
some people I've seen your brain think
we have yeah you know okay
should we go back to you go talk to so
the place Tarsus alright that's four
Tarsus and let's get a mission so do we
need to do yeah we've got if you look at
your your HUD we've got a whole lot of
people who talk to you I'll speak to
this guy go back into for tossing
himself this guy's just thanking me
thanking us really for helping get his
business back on and he's instilling the
virtues of how you got to look good
shall I say my gun inspires or that I
like to look cool I like to look cool
let's move on next mission I'm gonna let
you drive that mission because I think
this is just ketchup we're just having a
chinwag fair enough I I actually can't
get into for tarsus why the doors closed
they don't want you in there they don't
I'm sure it's not the blue marker that
you're going towards maybe I will come
down here it just says start expedition
think say let's find any missions we
should have a new one now I've just
talked to this guy whose name escapes me
Owen I think it's going yeah well you
are in charge when we're in the we're in
the hub world you are ok I'll follow you
captain ok do I like celebrating
birthdays can you man question what is
it
we gotta start thinking about next oh
gosh having a lovely chat back birthday
so we ended it on a good note though but
he's coming too obviously we tried to
burn the freelancer lifestyle yeah so
now I mean to a national you can't
control these things so maybe we need to
take it on a more positive turn a more
jovial turn yeah remind everyone about
the fun sure investing so yeah I think
it's very important all right we have
everything yeah I've already favor to
ask
that's our new mission I think all right
go for it hopefully I can select it
favorite ask okay are you guys all in
yep you are ready up yes yes we're in ok
anthem anthem time yeah so what well
who's doing the lines to win so I can
[Music]
believe in your dreams and your dreams
will believe in you your javelin can be
many colors like pink orange I'm done
speaking of promote we should probably
remind people that there is a
competition oh yes yes what are the what
are the rules the competition the rules
are if you go to gain spot Twitter
Souter calm for it slash gain spot
there's a tweet there which you can we
retweets and you also need to tag three
of your friends because you can then win
for code so that's enough codes for you
can afford you can't have three friends
check it before like I do it's wonderful
yeah go retweet that and you could win
Marty's in tho lies happy to be your
friend okay uphold freelance freelancer
traditions guys come on guys we're doing
the clothes cool just a conference call
spiders Oh
spiders are here straightaway all right
well done okay
I have to auto rifles this let's get up
in the sky and let's do it they're
predators cleared 11 out of 12 where's
the last one where are you this is why
I'm not doing well how many killed one
of them okay I can't figure out where
may be going right there oh there's a
thing he should be on our radar a little
red dot sight unless he's in an egg like
we need to go and destroy all of the
eggs
I just got an uncommon Ember predators
cleared there's one more predator yes
sir oh I see a red red door I see him oh
I see him as well
I saw him first he line yeah I miss I
scared it today
all right interact with Memorial a
dedication to the freelancers who gave
their lives at the Battle of GAO's
choice clear the memorial sites okay
let's go be respectful you got another
chance to try and take those wyverns out
from from a swift punching all right
here we go there's a lot punch though I
totally messed it up this one oh I can
at this guy I can launch that a recharge
dome like in the sky so I just sit
inside it there it's there you appear to
be frozen no no okay I just stand still
and let them come to me and they die in
my little ring that's great nice lure
yeah exactly perfect trap my my new
powers don't seem to be oh god they're
requiring some new learning and I don't
think I'm doing particularly well so I
could be swiftly moving from first to
last again oh god oh god oh no I'm done
well yeah right next to lot zealots is
running away running away you've got a
big spider there so it's fun into your
time big thing the big thing thank you
oh I got you good freezing effects on
this new power though
all right we're all right green thing is
here got it
nope don't fly they're not that far away
I think you're better off on the ground
oh they're just here there it is oh yeah
one right here as well somewhere
is that it yes you guys are finding
these real well
Oh in the blips I'm following the blips
and finding nothing just randomly change
direction it means you're on top of it
when there happens we're all right I
found one no thanks there we go okay
here we go like the fire that should go
in their anthem anthem yeah right the
fire team Altima
yeah there it goes you can't cancel it
follow the waist that might be the fifth
time of them that
Oh someone just went up to the side what
did you find huh oh yeah it goodies yeah
there's a lot of enemies where I've just
arrived oh yeah oh you know they're
coming up oh hi pal ones as well oh wow
oh God
watch out for the laser weapons oh yeah
all right I'm going to putting a dumb
down here alright so we need to retrieve
the stolen equipment as a matter of
priority I think you say they're gonna
keep gonna deal with these guys than the
other ones guys you get the thing
alright yeah you suck him up and I'll
get the next one
yeah yeah do it because I am a bouncy
drop out of the sky oh there's no this
one's this one's surrounded by guys yes
the bad ones will go for but I've got it
anyway yeah I I tried that alright we
got a rule oh oh oh
lots of pain all sorts of pain whatever
the guys in the rocket bus oh god okay
really badly hurt
pretty sure we're from as well
those moments my brain just shut off
because I just concentrate kill kill
yeah yeah exactly
it's got hard all of a sudden it's
gotten really hard I am very low on
health yeah okay let's let's team up
who's got defensive powers I've got a
dome here yeah I'm coming to you all
right dome dome up get in the dome in
the dome
afraid of not put in a very good place
we can't see any of the enemies but
we're safe at a health yeah see it
worked was all my plan all along
lure them into the dome he goes he goes
dad good plan I'm gonna put the things
in the thing did the freelance oh I
think I'm gonna be coming last in this
mission you you you underestimate me sir
no I've done quite poorly oh oh right
I'm gonna go in with my electrics
okay the camp oh my god I've frozen
everything say ultimate
I've got a recharge dome for well I just
landed in the water today I'm gonna just
drop it weighs up so if you if if anyone
spends any time in this dome it
recharges your abilities quickly all
right
I'll drop my protection dome here as
well my James all right get in my dome
he said come on edge up in my Dame my
dome is about to die oh no I got you
cover me
I'm saving Lottie all right go slay more
nerds thank you
all right we're done right yeah I see no
red yeah I would never do telling
stories of your own life I've stopped
looking for the markers now I just think
where you guys fly a team camp yeah we
do oh god H detector one that was
nothing a flare can't be cause quick
quick quick
there we go grenade yeah I think we are
gonna have a slight change of fates here
oh yeah you don't think you're gonna
finish on top this time don't think so
[Music]
we're gonna find out there wasn't many
big big guys do that together and I was
practicing execution sounds good I'm
gonna skip to the end yeah let's find
out the results
yeah I'm lost hey I'm still not first
god lot C well done beautiful sorry we
be tied yeah I'll take this Ben that's
good you know it's all about progression
it's always because I resprayed you you
see all right you made me well I got
pilot level increase wheat of course I'm
never late finally you guys ready you
ready for some quiz yes Oh born ready
all right let me go to the forge I
sloped to go to the forage it's a thing
we don't have to feel the glare anthem
is all about playing together with your
squad teammates buddies or as we call
them friends so in the popular sitcom
Friends row say we are on a break Oh
what I have no idea
season 7 episode 1 B season 4 episode 24
C season 2 episode 10 or D season 3
episode 15 till having them again please
alright 7 episode 1 for episode 24 to 10
or 3 alright season 3 episode yes take
that and what's his name crime I got you
there you go he's literally red come on
cam oh man this is not good for the for
the board it's good yes it is good for
the book bossy is top the board yeah I
mean Simon you've done well the fact
that you've only had one question to
answer you got it right so that's pretty
good can believes in me 30 seconds ago I
was too busy getting it right over the
relationship breaking up between Ross
Geller and Rachel Green all right here
yep
friends are still incredibly popular
with like young people mid timed a radio
host anyway let's move on I'm glad my
trivia is better than the game here we
go who would who would like to
redecorate and respray my my javelin you
got choose feel like I might give this
to Lottie me yeah yeah so you can take
that all right go for it okay okay you
know sunset I'm good I'm good for sunset
okay
are we timing it oh you're timing it man
ten seconds in okay this is gonna be
speedy work here okay
glorious stunning yeah unless you want
to change it from lovely yep get quite
tequila sunrise at the main yeah it
really is it's a heavy and a bit of the
red okay beautiful
twenty seconds to go
oh you're doing the Cape the most
important bit I like this bird yes I'm
happy
it was tactical let I see tactical loss
yeah he's very value exactly okay let's
let's figure out our next mission
situation I think February I got new
components actually one memento what do
I have
new components I have a new convergence
core calm down everybody
increases impact damage blast damage no
I think I'm gonna stick with my I think
I I should probably change up what I
just had because I was obviously not
doing very well with it at all he blasts
where's my dome let's go back to that
weapons with anything new no gear no new
Vista I am gonna give myself reissue
myself an assault rifle because that
marksman rifle while good is its kind of
tricky I haven't that good so awful for
ages
I'm dual wielding pistols right now all
right I'm getting field yeah quickening
alright living flame all right well good
hold two exits we're out all right yeah
respray is done so new mission who's
first in me me I was like whoever's on
this you have us on the mainstream I'll
be literally meet ya
right so II see if we have any ready to
go so Luke so one of the things I I
really like about for Tarsus now versus
the demo is that in the demo you were
limited to one speed and now they've
added a brisk pace walk I think is weak
this is still dis em what free lunches
do is still there do we maybe have to do
this again I let's let's jump in it's
quick I don't understand why I'd be here
if we didn't have to do it yeah let's do
it I mean maybe maybe we didn't do it
and I just saw this title and thought oh
yeah that's possible let's do that right
okay just always wanted what real
answers do yeah exactly yeah let's find
it apparently paralyzed I'm 64
nerds leah is 45 sorry 54 I guess I
can't read sab is 66 and Rhyno thing is
6161
we gotta get either the big guns
literally the big gun we do he gets to
go far we've grown up
we were mere tens when we started this
journey yes you want the biggest
mountain to climb on this that design
look at it Wow oh yes anthem anthem time
oh right yeah so it's is it you and I I
was neither first nor laughs wait who
was first you are naughty naughty
instead it's fine
I don't make the rules all right do you
wanna go first
yeah okay that should be the line do you
want to go first
what about grab its we haven't heard
anything like rabbits innocence I'm just
gonna I was gonna I'll work up to that
for now I'm gonna say wyverns wyverns
the scourge of the skies okay let's go
to the skies
Oh javelins you find people chaplains
are fine people all right let's find out
let's let's fly up are you going the
wrong way
oh yeah oh you're going the right way I
feel like we've done this we may have
yeah it's weird that that's there guys
I'm gonna be really upset
oh wait hold on when I go home and play
this I'll be able to play as my juggling
yeah oh my god Best Musical how do you
think you're about to get a reset when
you went back home yeah you're playing
on your own account now we have
definitely done Merry Christmas to me
yeah 100% we've done this should we do
it on the market yeah let's back out
okay this happened I'm not sure why
that's happened they okay various for
Tarsus yeah the fighting you mission me
mission or the free play yes true be and
free play yeah we can do free play yeah
should we give that a go yes
cuckoo free play it is need so what is
free play said free play is the open
world where there are various different
quests and small missions that can be
completed hey hey he won this one
[Laughter]
nothing I'm I'm taking this win alright
to Tarsus accomplished nothing the true
the true life of a feel actually done
some work yeah right okay so we're gonna
explore the what's it called again the
free play free play right and there's
like well Bastion what did that before
there is there's like big beasts and
stuff around there are can fight there
are number of different things yeah so
we should be able to just hold why jump
straight back and then if you go to game
mode free play okay and then you choose
oh you can choose a free play area we
currently have two free play areas do
you guys want to go to the Academy ruins
or the nori play let's go to Academy
ruins yeah all right so it's good sound
suggest more words yeah keeping on
difficult I think we need to invite
lofty back into there we do oh we should
hate this for some reason you never
appear in my friends
so I'm gonna have to go into the Xbox
settings and invite you from there oh no
that said I mean everyone's that yeah
you know what listen why don't we see
what someone else is doing well I do
this really boring task I do like the
way I know we've meant this before do
you like the way you crack the floor
when you land yeah this makes me happy
that is what I noticed that there you
have it in vitality oh thank you very
much no problem except we in where do we
go from the end in terms of environment
ready we've got for the Academy ruin
yeah
you guys ready up I'm ready here we go a
giant school learn for a while actually
throwing gentlemen how to jab all right
this is my game
yes time so you don't be trying I've
been so upset that there was a bald joke
within the first okay my-my-my Pete came
to very very quick and I have at least
win one cam needs to come up with an
anthem line I've become neither first
nor last yeah that's all right
all these great lines these zingers
waiting waiting to be deployed into the
air but it also means well it's run out
you can just like completely disowned it
kind I take no responsibility to be
honest so you could come up with an
anthem line now because we are still
loading would you like give me your pity
lines cheese I'll give you a lot in in
them
I'm just so desperate I'd rather
deliberately lose that way javelins are
fine people okay
all right where we going left girl we'll
follow you yes I'm assumed done off to
find adventure
hopefully adventurous things Jesus not
there yeah I really do feel like
superhero Miami crab thing Oh crab
that's gone well yep it stopped we ended
a life oh he's got lots of armor my guns
doing zero damage apparently there we go
yeah feel good there we go something has
come up on the map yeah let us head
there well they can move very quickly oh
they can what we got the 50 these
outlaws as well I've gone way ahead of
you I'm in trouble
hold on Rhino thing so I'm gonna set
nicly preempted the challenge idea that
we had oh wow a game show oh yes there
we go man you go friend Oh
I'm gonna color with is if there's a
flying jerk applying Jack get him who
froze me
alright James a jerk Oh whoever did that
freeze attack fair play no one as well
oh I'm coming
absolutely sorry I'm coming here we go
here we go he's dead ha bring me back to
life
it's good to be sorry who was our
friends were in trouble
he was he had a great time that's like I
forgot any time for you can anytime you
don't even have to ask your friends we
are really this is this whole stream is
just a trial of our friendship so far
it's going very well I think so I'm very
happy right more stuff over here
Oh loads of guys over there it would see
there were another one just don't crowd
him oh yes the hit of these guys is
actually put some on the floor
oh nice larious and then each guy there
nice ultimate time
that's gone quite well yeah like this
free play with melee attacks alone that
was ridiculous on your feet
thanks bro I've already let myself down
where are the people kill see you see a
red dot but no one taking responsibility
no I missed him guys someone she him
while I'm in educating him anybody Wow
oh it's all under the bridge it's all
going off under here hey we complete a
thing oh yeah come on open this chest
game's treasure all right where to next
well Sammy chose last time yeah I'm done
lotty direction and we'll follow you
okay let's go formation flying it's nice
and we will take off like that
it feels like we're a real team and then
we have an unbreakable bond that will
last sometimes I just drop my arse for
fun to see what comes out it's dead I
was cool enough I followed as well I
just follow as like a go in there I'll
go too
I think there are some bad guys there
yeah I don't know well yeah there's some
shiny things
did I go ahead I did I did Rupert's
weird birds dead birds I'm miles behind
now I'm coming
oh wait I think these these might be
harmless definitely no they're not
harmless then almost all guys over there
there we go
killing all the citroën is it foreigner
foreigner there we go oh wait in the
solarium Court down here that's cool all
right do it after yeah okay let's go
let's go get these guys what's going on
big people
oh there's a energy or something let's
go get it okay we need fragments guys
let's punch wyverns alright I'm gonna
try and punch a wyvern darn it I missed
this is yes got it oh oh I had it oh
look there's a really big dude down here
yeah and there's a ton of grenades on
the floor let's hop up someone help me
okay six straight ahead straight ahead
of you
I caught me yeah you can okay oh you
just dodged his attack that was really
good okay we've got quite a lot of
damage on him already I thought my
ultimate I should be able to take him
out they say no just get out of there
see if you're done good work sir well
he's getting low though no I kill me in
one that's why they get close to it
please so much help I'll take it
sacrifice one for the team this whistle
around just on your feet thank you it
was worth it oh that was great
what should we do well we're gonna find
some stuff here it's bad yeah what is
that a death bird that's the wyverns I
found it make a very very scary noise up
close
what's that bomb found it
another one up here somewhere yep cool
yes I'm fine in the mall so such a weird
tracking system another thing done
two for two Oh both chest oh oh where is
it over here oh yeah it marks on the map
oh nice many lovely things it's fun that
you you don't know what the loot is
gonna be and yeah you get to the end of
the mission yeah you're like what
goodies do they get it's fun
I feel like this is gonna be a loot
heavy as enemies over here there's still
some wirings in this guy can punch him
I'm overheating it's gone horror once
you hit the punch button there's nothing
doing until you land oh you can boost
again if you if you're not overheat easy
I tried that and it really it said no
maybe I'm wrong
all right where to whose turn is it to
lead I think it might be cams I'm
currently in this guy about overheat
here we go alright that's why I look for
annelida yeah yeah let's look at the old
map alright so the way I was gonna go is
in one way we can't go I like it I love
how it shows your path look at this oh
and I'm all over the shop yeah we're
gonna go this way
oh we can go we can keep going to the
edge we're going this way
the way I'm facing alright yeah boss
through the arch let's go
on your tail waggle dance a nice white
waggle dancing so Oh gifts so when I
first got my xbox 360 I didn't know
what's name I can't but I was drinking a
beer at the time called a waggle dancing
[Laughter]
so excited yeah it was a really tasty
honeyed beer which hence the term while
dancing no yeah you did ask me I can now
never hum no yeah well you can forget I
see those two things is different
enemies more of these armor jerks oh I
see oh nice that was good Wow yeah as my
ultimate Oh something sounds mad oh
these are friendly but you've made even
rage those lips oh god I didn't mean to
shoot them never shoot me in the butt
about this alright leader oh yeah I'm
leading I'm basically just looking for
things to fly through I think it's a
strong moral and literal compass
fighters well they're not a spiders bit
digesters wow that's one reason to kill
him yeah there's no good way to go
speaking of flying through things what's
in here
minerals yes like here you can choose to
hold X and harvest them or you can just
melee them Oh Kenny yeah I didn't know
that
observe you don't even have to hit them
very well
Oh what are these things I don't know
cute little foxes expedition now yeah
it's exploring the world Oh morning's
edge this is cool this is say hey
alright I'm passing the reins over to
you sir I brought this new area but no
mission guys look at these over there
yeah if anything anything called for the
anthem song alright my leadership says
we're going to the castle viewing
platform that's lovely the fortress
O'Malley get cool move it as well this
way no tune oh my subs are we gon say
wait wait wait coming in from the top
here is called red ready semi go there
are enemies below us
sorry can we kill them yeah it's more of
the armored guys yeah I keep hitting
them and it's doing zero damage no what
alright I'm gonna do it melee all the
way from the sky get out of my door
enemy my dome she's gone he's gone
arey ticket all right back to the castle
thank you
funny we could fly the power of light
this is really cool this is incredible
fly through the hole oh god that didn't
work this is amazing that was a riot so
what is this what is going on here no
seeing one red dot but just one it's
really serene right here is weird isn't
it's like almost unsettling oh wait
we've got a mission marker it is
actually away from this castle
[Laughter]
architecture is incredible
Kam's awesome to go sightseeing way that
I've seen it now don't follow me I make
dumb decisions I was a big guy big guy
big guy oh he's huge
let's try this again all right Simon
take two I just get out of there before
ends
oh I'll leave I'll make a dough for you
oh oh my god guys he ended me one here
Simon come to my dome okay I'm leaving
I'm leaving I'm leaving
oh you're the wrong way good all right
well you guys well you guys do the
killing I'm gonna try and complete the
actual mission I'm gonna I'm sorry just
saving our team thank you
no no no I'm not being facetious I'm
literally trying to complete the
missions anybody have an ultimate yes I
got it
let's go there he goes nice watch out
there Lottie let's get one tick kill the
one on the right first yeah absolutely
he's almost done he's almost done he's
down all right oh my goodness I'm sooo
trouble and I'm afraid I'm alright domes
fresh out of domes oh he's coming for me
sorry he's always right sugar
pretty gun oh no oh no oh no he's very
nearly dead
he's very nearly dead great work team
let's go guys what are these
well these blue things oh they grenades
all right we got a blip right whatever
what's the actual thing we're meant to
be doing the blip resigned a little
lippy things they're kind of everywhere
I found one yeah they've got weight is
it blue thing yeah give a little blue
glow and then take it take it
oh there's another one over here if
someone comes to me there's another one
here I can only pick one up at time
though so you got this one there you go
oh where do we have to take it - oh yeah
Center the map one more fragment cams
got it oh no we not I think we are we're
finished
brilliant good work yeah good event
where class oh yeah okay so we just it's
just oh there's a check I mean not like
we're gonna get spawned out everyone's
still worried yeah I think we should go
look at some Lube right yeah hey guys I
mean there is enemies let's get in fine
oh it's just any little scorpions
if there's easy now
I see why they anymore birds
darn it there we go birds recoil on this
gun is mad come here why then punches
there I'm happy about that yes good good
okay shall we head back to Fort Carson
said let's go on another mission we've
got as well yeah it's gonna be a decent
salute and the free play yeah stuff
going up in this house all right we see
what we got I declare that water time we
still do win lose for this one less we
do right if we're quick we've got
because I think there's 30 minutes left
on the stream so from quick we can do
this and be one more mission yeah so
let's do this super quick cool all right
we still need to see who's getting a
respray so cam you're the only one who's
not been resprayed that's true maybe
that just by default someone should
respray me now so skip to the end it's
for all right cam is the winner yes
finally
yeah vindication and Simon conspiracy
cool all right quick quick questions
all right so Simon you are - yeah
- question that's a lot of the exosuits
an anthem known as javelins provide you
with the ability to jump huge distances
fly effortlessly throughout the air
bending the laws of physics into your
world which the four sentences of
Newton's law are false Hey objects in
motion tend to stay in motion unless
acted upon B for every action there is
an equal and opposite reaction C
[Laughter]
thanks Uncle Ben acceleration yeah I
think okay it was see see you spider-man
I got you so you know as a point to
serve and a point to care okay next
question
spider-man anthem story spans over hours
of gameplay
to real question the real question a
question that was asking that question
hey Greece be Japan see South Africa D
the USA longest ever written so again
the longest national anthem ever written
in terms of duration of the Greece Japan
South Africa USA ABCD I'm gonna go for
I'm gonna go with whatever you don't go
for Greece a Japan let's see I'm very
very decide that this person has come
flying back cam you are correct Wow
Thank You Greece Greece has the longest
national anthem ever rode which is not
true because we're about to write anthem
at one point okay so that means you
didn't really get screwed over there
so I mean coming from from the back and
having to miss out on two-point
opportunity right it just means later on
when I go home and cry at least I've got
a reason for it this evening you see do
we want to do the respray of the house
of respray working now oh yes except m7
is your turn to respray to respray me oh
right okay yeah I'll do a casual respray
they are my friend go nuts enjoy I'm
gonna sit back relax see what you're
gonna get is probably our last mission
Lottie I'm gonna
I'm gonna let you respray mine oh really
we are a wonderful team okay as you see
I've gone for all the colors of the
rainbow white and black you go to a job
interview camera at the moment don't
look smart
garlic smart for my big day I think you
choose the color of the metal currently
so it's not gonna show up because the
change would first change it oh no sorry
yeah yeah there you go and go over to
that one yeah yeah no wait what sorry
hold on yours is a little difficult I
think it's same hot pink although I
didn't see where the hot pink was
applied white like it it's not making
massive difference is it if I somehow
baked in this color I think I'm good for
this or I might do want to slightly
tweak oh there we go okay I'm trying to
I'm making this too nice I think it's
cuz I've made everything that hex pink
there may be something in anthem where
things just look cool and nice yeah that
would be my think I'm just gonna go I
think I'm probably gonna go with that
you can just tweet the worst day and
then what a vinyl make this yeah okay
alright we're good thanks
it's like a bit like a pack of mints
don't know what that means you don't
completely honest thanks man
well you two have unwittingly followed a
very similar design oh yeah well here I
was I was thinking going of some really
aggressive clashing colours but thanks
good wrestling tech team that's good
okay trust me
okay thanks and please very pleased
would be alright happy yeah thank you
very much
okay cool alright alright we got 25
minutes
do a mission Shirley let's do your
mission while you're doing that I came
out of the forge max I'm gonna go back
in the fall I see explosions on target
it's all thing we want to do I just
quickly doing a new master points rapid
throw rapid bolts of fire
I'm just doing some new components
things we don't do this oh yeah I'm also
doing some components ammo damage all
right I'm gonna keep mine as is yeah
let's do it in support what's this it's
a final mission go back your wind wall
that was good yeah win wars coming back
making a glorious return all right I am
I'm good I'm good to go
good probably I should have bought you
know a and some kind of extra thing like
an animation or I see I have enough
things enough in-game well we should
probably mind people say how they can do
what we're doing that's a good point win
yeah I mean codes for the game so
explain there's competition going on if
you head over to twitter.com forward
slash game spots and retweet the tweet
they have put out it was about five past
three and if you retweet that tagging
three of your friends you will be in a
in with a chance to win or Xbox one
codes for anthem so you are building
your squad and getting a code for each
of you so if you haven't done that
already go do it now
definitely there you go absolutely do
not you're securing us the mission so I
think that icon means have a chitchat
and I think this icon means have a
contract let's get a contract let's get
a contract hello future me yeah to a
good bid that guy yeah cuz that were you
going for cameras maybe it's also cams
usual office that's tested it yeah yeah
he comes to work dress like that a bunch
that's negative right yeah it looks nice
the yellow he's got his gloves powerful
gloves all right hold the start
expedition did we just get her a mission
yes find out well hold to start we'll
find out that we go you're the you're
the boss mission change mission we still
only have days confusing let's try let's
keep keep going for it he will give us
something it's also other markers it is
I've not even been here whoa this is a
whole new part of for Tarsus didn't know
we had access to mmm
yeah this massive it's very exciting I'm
all about like mini hub world you can
just walk around yeah between missions
I always please haha hello hello are you
getting a new mission it's being
dissented oh yes all right I'm in the
interest of getting the mission done I'm
gonna skip this conversations yeah
mission did that give us one I think it
did
yes yes your presence at Arcanist base
okay
launch launch it let's go yes okay yeah
that one please so this is it then this
is if I actually don't want to be an
abomination and many lose pretty much
every game I got to win everybody ready
up I'm ready oh sorry said that was me
that was me my bad my bad
I'm ready ready said we go I wasn't
ready serving I was lazy said we go if
you lose this one said will change your
gamertag yeah okay I think two of you
have to come up with some anthem anthem
loo so I camera we had last time
no neither can i oh javelins are fine
people okay people
yeah houston the other line
so when you leave me on here I need
something to work on okay um
fly through the sky and I believe in
your mite wyverns need punching and
that's it and that's it part of the
anthem it is okay I love the wyverns are
featured twice they're the secret star
event that we figured not only do you
get to watch us play this game but
you're gonna witness the greatest song
of all time also probably end of all of
our careers I look forward to that I
knew it was coming for a while yes I
believe rich is taking note of the
lyrics right gibbering I don't remember
rich knows music therefore I know he's
giving me this one there okay okay all
right
can we all sync up hit the bricks can I
be friends I'm giving you a slow clap
all right let's go to the market yeah
let's go all right this looks an awful
lot like the beginning of the other
mission it is what freelancers do but
this is different okay
we are we are going to the same people
though maybe there's just a number of
missions to start over here
there must be oh it's not the same
though it isn't oh I flew into a tree
all right
just if we have never been amis enemies
folks good job I decided overheat a new
gun oh there's a big is a big flying
baddie thing this guy tell them oh my
gosh you got it drags you down when you
jump up where is he where is he
everywhere combo let's go grab it throws
him
thank you
[Music]
I've got a dome if anyone wants it let's
right behind you rent a thing become the
dome nice nice thing I'm like you new
powers new powers are good powers yeah
then there's no miss keeping these good
and safe I am always surprised by the
new powers when you were equipped with
some kind of scar hunter here nice
lovely okay there's a massive guy on the
other side just everyone knows thanks
red coming to join over on this side oh
yeah they are
all right frozen wall nice yes very nice
get the big guy there's a dome up here
if anyone needs protection
really I should have put it down there
but ultimate oh oh I'm in trouble I am
in trouble
- I am really - everyday on - gung ho
I've really got to stop there
oh god this guy this guy's powerful
don't get close to this car scale
Oh sharp my words there are some crazy
snipers around I'm doing ultimate do it
do it do it
oh wow mani scallops they're there
they're hearty there's one down here
next it yeah that guy get him Simon all
right where are you gonna work makes the
dream work by the worst time what's up
Jesus
okay investigate Skaar presence at
Arcanist base to the blue marker to the
blue Walker get green loot thing
delicious the bullet Myers so many looks
like gorgeous canyons very is very
pleasing on the eyes it's a very nice
environment yeah water yeah I'm flying
like a cool kid yeah that's cool makes
you feel that you're faster huh
I could fly this is how I fly all the
time by somebody's they just scrappers
so it shouldn't be too bad
this new weapon so good the weapons are
good all around I think what's this
freezing attack you got service great so
it's this thing where basically I create
a dome over people and they all free and
they and they just yeah freeze exactly
where they are all right we got Lipper's
hunt the blips I think I'm stood on top
of a blip but I'm seeing it it's around
here somewhere here it is this is this
pile here yeah thank you
looking for piles of stuff all right
Oh kill the things oh these things yeah
all right I'll use that frizzy thing
listen wannabes up this way
Wow Challenge completed we are really
destroying these girls yeah getting much
much better at this is that a is this
machine to think so machine pistol
that's really good
yeah we got marker marker over here yeah
I've got one over here I should start
trying the pistol because I generally go
straight past them because I'm like
that's a pistols yeah too much pistol
judgment over here really I look like
that mineral we've had Lottie inside it
ok so I'd say we got 10 minutes we're
good there and then we need to do the
anthem anthem yeah people to waiting
around yeah yeah I mean the game is one
thing but we can see this quest through
in 10 minutes easy
oh this is really pretty to me you'd
call it the interiors but I will they're
cool enemies Zeb you just flew past a
bunch of them today but I'm killing
these ones oh nice
yep there goes my shields oh who was
that Ultimates oh oh don't over here yet
come down sit down hello up near the
entrance I think I'm on a sniper oh you
get em out cover this let's give Sheen
the sniper
where are you saving you up I'm down I'm
hanging out are you up be there on my
knees checking out yeah hey there is my
good friend hey you deserve good points
for that I won't give it oh yeah if you
see like a red laser on you just like
jumping the sky in booster way that
would or hit B quickly or a hippie
counter snipe
who is this guy oh I can fly in
electrocute that's sick that is sick
we've got an elite scar hunter right
next to me in the dome oh he's just
destroyed my dome I see him let's go
hard where I'm electric jump on it as
well
there is yeah he's dead yeah not our guy
okay show you guys there now he's dead
here Daffy done did that favor so so
involved we're trying to do I just kind
of switched off just fell into the game
right yes done
the music's going off I whittled since
we be there that was cool Oh catch up
with you guys imagine we're about to run
into some crazy crazy resistance yep
narrow tunnels expert piloting required
go well and a little bit of cooling down
oh yeah
here we go oh all right
I'm gonna oh is a big guy here oh yeah
okay I'm gonna throw down and boom here
feel free to get it real quick with this
guy here oh he is a big guy oh wow that
was awesome he's frozen it's frozen
let's go come back there's something out
there firing really big shells and it
took in my film in one so well it wasn't
that guy cuz he's dead or this thing
oh this type is I don't know what this
is but Oh another big guy really big guy
in fact I'm just gonna go hang out keep
forgetting to use where people aren't
abilities oh God oh no he's flaming me
mm-hmm
everyone all right yeah I'm nearly dead
I'm very very very nearly dead
fortunately it so I frozen the big guy
we can get him now no no he's back to
life yeah I couldn't find him now you
still up Cara Mia yeah I'm fine
[Music]
they're all grouped together could
really use a an ultimate right now I was
an elite enforcer again a big one yes Oh
the sniper some way just got me bad same
I just I just thought oh no come on guys
just realise the one of the powers I've
got I can use five times in a row and
I've just been using it once in a row
[Laughter]
start getting a bit more aggressive oh
dear I am down there's a lot of people
around town we had explodey like spider
things
oh say bye I'm right next to where oh
you're in a really hard to reach place
man I didn't do this I have no idea I'm
going alternate I got you don't work on
ultimate as well it's required what do
we do it what's happen on I'm killing
this big guy he's dead nice Oh spiders
everywhere oh yeah all right oh I'm down
critical failure I critically failed
where is he where is that dead spiders
everyone right yeah yep we got three
minutes and then the anthem anthem
begins let's try and get this mission we
can get the mission done with this big
guy you've got a little bit of wiggle
room with me yeah oh yeah we do actually
yeah yeah let's just get the mission
done yeah oh I find a thing that made me
finding all right let you know we frozen
now yeah I think these guys are gonna
never-ending they keep on coming forever
oh yes fragments let's go get the
fragments I've got one all right I'm
gonna put you know the spinning blue
thing I was shooting for a while
so I don't think you can
where's one I don't think you can fly
when you've got fragment you can jump
okay that's another one all right so one
more to go I got it I'll get rid of all
this fighters if you need yeah let's go
I love it where's our loot crate I bet
you're not gonna sleep oh the crate
there that went really well
yeah we have definitely got better but I
think that free play
gave us quite an advantage because we'd
definitely upgraded our loot yeah we
really did I just my ultimate just a lot
where's that crazy their crates no crate
these are any things that matter to me
that was perfectly timed
yeah so a lot to you know just go and
like salvage everything now you actually
do get double of things as well so I'll
judge the dummies and the stuff that you
know level two stuff and whatever I
don't know what the word Salvage means
we so is that we're not adding any more
lines do we need a finale line written
by the winner in least I'll have two
questions laughter doing those yes okay
hold on oh wow
what's the let's see see what damages oh
come on Simon rubbish again no go lossy
words he wins yes I said and a weird
twist of fate Simon
we're almost you almost got me I'm in
today ah they're really important things
that I've liked flowers and walk down
the beach made on the latest frostbite 3
engine anthem is a third-person action
role-playing game but which body part is
the most susceptible to frostbite a toes
B tongue C eyes D hair here its toes
toes say them again
a toes B tongue C eyes D hair point that
is correct 9 the final question is
javelins allow the freelancers to have
superhuman strength endurance and
agility yeah however in the 1984 Berlin
Olympics and I knew you expecting that
how far was the men's longest recorded
jabot ok ok a 100 point 5 meters be
seventy six point seven four meters C
one hundred and four point eight zero
meters or D 88 meters I'm gonna go with
88 88 d locked in how far how far is the
javelin throw I'm gonna go with ya I'm
going I'm going I'm gonna go 88 100
point five seventy six point seven four
one hundred four point eight or eighty
eight I know 76 76 point seven four well
amazingly for the first time in the
anthem quiz everybody got it wrong you
see 104 point eight I've lost the
important thing is if you look at the
score we can all see who won wait score
yes
even though I've
yeah we learned many things today we
have such as I am the best I knew that
before I walked in here so the true
meaning of song yeah because we have two
more lines to write we do yeah is a rim
on the whiteboard YouTube there is this
room on the whiteboard okay so who would
like to go first
I don't mind lot lines for this shoot
your gun and shoot it proud and don't
forget this is the lifeline and to find
and find a loot crate makes me proud
it's a Riley's proudly proud that's
right Crowley pram you're gonna prom
with it you come talk to us who's
singing this could be anxious music
because it's play you can turn it down
in your little mix let's just go okay
okay okay no I think we should sing it
okay yeah well you guys think about this
okay
not enough frankly or we could break it
into segments if you want like we can
keep the first two we'll first one okay
I'll take the first one
all right we're going with line each
okay let's see this Oh glory to Tarsus
magnificent you I do you no justice
anthem for I am not worthy the
freelancers life is a life believe in
your dreams and your dreams will believe
in you you're traveling like pink orange
and blue the scourge of the skies
[Music]
punching like if you got someone and put
a gun to the head and say you write
something now we got a monkey you just
gave it right we got AI to watch us play
this the whole time
yeah that's like an AI create obviously
that needs to be put in the game now
just that song on your pain at all that
is a salt on to the hold Simon and
Lottie Thank You genuinely really
enjoyed that
yes four-person squad absolutely
especially just having you guys like
locally set together yeah if you enjoyed
watching that and you fancy playing it
for yourself there's still time to enter
the competition if you go to twitter.com
forward slash GameSpot retweet the tweet
tag three of your friends you could be a
chance to win for Xbox one codes so why
not do that fantastic well thank you all
for watching um I'm cam this is Cedric
Lottie and Simon and to stay tuned for
more anthem stuff make sure you keep
here on GameSpot calm
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]